en este vídeo vamos a pensar como el
comercio entre dos países puede alterar
el equilibrio los precios y las
cantidades en un mercado determinado lo
que vemos aquí como nos gusta hacer son
ejemplos simplificados de mercados en
distintas economías primero tenemos al
país
y digamos que tenemos el mercado de
aplicaciones y supongamos que el país
no está negociando con nadie más es
decir es una autarquía que es una
palabra elegante para decir que este
país opera de manera independiente opera
en aislamiento aquí puedes ver la curva
de demanda de este mercado en color rojo
y también por acá puedes ver la curva de
oferta y puedes ver que cuando este país
trabaja en aislamiento este mercado de
aplicaciones tiene un precio de
equilibrio que parece estar por debajo
de 4 pesos suponiendo que tenemos el
precio en pesos por aplicación y la
cantidad de equilibrio parece
por debajo de cuatro unidades para el
período de tiempo que estamos observando
muy bien ahora veamos al país ve
supongamos también que opera de manera
independiente es una autarquía en este
mercado podemos ver que tiene una curva
distinta de demanda que la que vimos en
el país
y también una curva de oferta distinta y
observa tiene un precio y una cantidad
de equilibrio diferente aquí el precio
de equilibrio parece ser ligeramente
arriba de un peso y la cantidad de
equilibrio parece no ser tan diferente
que en el caso anterior que la que vimos
en el país
sin embargo en muchas situaciones será
diferente
ahora imaginemos qué es lo que pasará si
abren sus economías el uno al otro bueno
en este momento vamos a sumar de manera
horizontal esas dos curvas de demanda y
también sumaremos de manera horizontal
estas dos curvas de oferta para obtener
una nueva curva de oferta y una nueva
curva de demanda todo esto es un repaso
de lo que ya hemos visto en otros vídeos
ahora observa para el precio de cinco
pesos en total ninguno de los dos países
demanda nada no hay cantidad demandada
de aplicaciones y para un precio de cero
pesos para el país
el mercado está demandando 15 unidades
mientras que para el país ve el mercado
está demandando 5 unidades por lo tanto
de manera conjunta demandan 20
aplicaciones de manera similar lo puedes
ver para la oferta para un precio de 5
pesos el país
ofrece 5 aplicaciones y para el precio
de 5 pesos el país le ofrece 15
por lo tanto en conjunto van a ofrecer
20 aplicaciones en un cierto periodo de
tiempo así que podemos ver esto como las
curvas de demanda y de oferta para
mercados combinados porque ahora
comercian entre ellos ya no estamos en
una autarquía y observa qué es lo que
sucede nuestro precio de equilibrio está
en alguna parte entre estos dos precios
de equilibrio anteriores parece estar
por debajo de los tres pesos y nuestra
cantidad de equilibrio está ligeramente
por debajo de las diez unidades
quiero que observes que suceden varias
cosas interesantes por aquí cuál será el
punto de vista de un consumidor en el
país
es decir de una persona que demanda esta
aplicación bueno ahora en lugar de pagar
casi cuatro pesos va a pagar un precio
entre dos y tres este es el nuevo precio
de equilibrios del país y abre su
economía por lo tanto lo que tenemos es
una cantidad que será producida en
teoría por fabricantes nacionales
digamos estas primeras dos unidades y
media y el resto de dónde saldrán bueno
serán unidades que se importen
ahora veamos qué es lo que sucede en el
precio de equilibrio del país ve el país
ve fue realmente el productor con menos
costo y observa que un nuevo precio de
equilibrio está por aquí digamos
ligeramente arriba de 2.5 y ahora tienes
una situación en donde los productores
en el país ve van a producir más mucho
más de lo que producían anteriormente
solo esta cantidad viene en su demanda
nacional y toda esta cantidad aquí será
algo que exporten
y si suponemos que toda la economía de
este mundo se da solo con el país a ive
o que solamente comercian entre ellos
entonces estas exportaciones se volverán
las importaciones del país y entonces
los que proponen el libre comercio dirán
mira el excedente general del consumidor
combinado es mayor que el excedente del
consumidor que teníamos antes antes
teníamos este excedente del consumidor
para el país
y para el país ve teníamos todo este
excedente pero aún así toda esta área
entera es más grande si quieres puedes
hacer los cálculos correspondientes
matemáticos calcular el área de estos
triángulos y de igual manera va a
ocurrir para el excedente del productor
el excedente total del productor de las
economías combinadas será mayor que el
excedente del productor para el país a
más el excedente del productor para el
país ve ahora
no es forzoso que siempre existan
ganadores en esto los ganadores aquí
serán los consumidores del país
porque en lugar de tener este pequeño
excedente del consumidor que tenían
antes ahora tienen este mayor excedente
del consumidor
los otros ganadores son los productores
del país ve porque en lugar de este
excedente del productor que tenían antes
ahora tienen este excedente del
productor mucho mayor sin embargo los
perdedores en esta situación son los
productores del país
que ahora tienen un excedente del
productor mucho menor es decir este
triángulo se encogió a este de aquí y
los perdedores en esta situación también
son los consumidores en el país ve que
ahora tienen que pagar un precio de
equilibrio mayor por lo tanto el
excedente del consumidor es ahora este
pequeño triángulo cuando antes era todo
este
de cualquier manera lo que quiero que te
lleves de este vídeo es que si cambias
la autarquía a una economía abierta
entonces esto puede afectar el
equilibrio los precios y las cantidades
del mercado también a menudo y
generalmente van a aumentar tu excedente
total del consumidor y del productor con
lo que existirán algunos ganadores y
otros perdedores en esta interacción es
todo por esta ocasión nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo